內五盤外五盤我們提一下
當時我們講到欲龍的時候
我們看欲龍 先看就可以欲龍
我們在這一天的 這天的時候吧
哪一天 這一天 是不是這一天
對 50幾塊那邊
在這天的時候 在講庭之前 你看到什麼現象 我畫給你看
这都知道吧
我们可以随便看两股票
你看那个预融1K图
那個Tigertool
打015
往這裡
是不是內5盤
這邊是外5盤
是不是外5盤
那一天
那一天在50
50出頭快的時候
這邊Maya是不是很多
賣壓是命運麻麻的
3200、2500、我幾千張 對不對
是不是這樣
那我是不是告訴你
不要怕這個東西
記不記得
記得吧
賣壓很重 不要怕
不要怕
可能賣出來的都
都不是真的賣壓
真正的賣壓一定是拉高所足及的
對不對
你這樣固定在賣的人
固定在賣的就兩種想法
我想解套
我就價格高了 我過得那麼賣
賣壓那麼多 買盤不成比例
比如說賣壓 假設賣壓
這邊是個toto的 五張對不對
假設賣壓是13000張好了
那這地方買盤
這邊買盤是不是一個toto
這是5000張
這兩次玄書不成比例
你看到你會不會想賣股票
會不會想賣股票
以前換錢
現在不會
因為交了2萬1就不會了
是不是
對 你知道達到目標嗎
是不是這樣子
以前賣押13000
買盤5000張
我怎麼供啊
是不是你第一個想
哇 敵人那麼多
沒錯吧
但是強勢股都是用外盤成交的
所以你看到假設這地方掛進是800張
隨便抽起來是5000張了
那麼這地方掛盤1500張
3000張 8000張好了
類似這樣了
是不是搞不滴動
但是你在排面上 你就會看到突然這東西不見了
突然這東西不見了
突然這東西不見了 那股價是不是上去了
是不是 所以不要被那假象騙到
我們上課地堂課告訴你 價格是什麼
虛幻的嘛 你們都會變成金剛金是不是
對不對 講一遍嘛
如夢幻泡影
然後呢 印作如是乾
那麼價格是這樣 也是這樣看 是不是
不要被外盤給嚇到了 相對的
不要被買盤太多給嚇到了 是不是
買盤如果太多 你放空 買盤如果太多
你放空會不會怕
不要怕卡肯尼
盤是弱就卡肯尼
因為這東西一旦破了
這些東西會變成賣壓
清楚嗎
現在不會了
賣盤很多
你以後會慢慢去統計做分析
做回歸分析的話
賣外五盤賣很多的
一旦被突破
這些都會反手變賣盤
懂嗎 就變成那種嘎空 清楚嗎
那麼你再想到 玉龍的那天 印象很深刻吧
講停盤 71塊2 71塊的時候
買盤很多很多很多 突然1900 07張
就1900 70張還是1千
直接把它打到69塊7
那買盤擺得這麼很多的
殺了之後就是抽單 是不是整個掛下來了
對不對
是不是印象很深刻
那時候
漲停板是71.2
賣壓可能很多
但是買盤是不是更多
那麼買盤更多
你是不是認為支撐很有支撐
對不對
71塊
706 707
你可能試試看708買
你買是不是一下子中獎了
再之後沒有708
是不是如此
所以內行的看什麼門道
外行的看熱鬧
是不是這樣子
不要被內武牌 外武牌
這些給胡容注了
老師 我們2023消品到來了
來了哪裡呢
就是我們的一級技術分析工藝班
因為我們從11月23號起
老師 為什麼五堂課
你突然變成13堂課 嚇死我了
我這樣子講
因為以前我都講
講重點
沒有舉實力圖
那因為我認為技術分析
武堂課錯錯有餘
那麼我說一直期望學生
根據我講的
你去找途去應徵去了解
然後我在盤中操作給你看
這是我當初的主要架構
那麼還是有很多很多的學生
他不了解這一塊
不了解蕭老師
蕭老師的用心良苦
用心良苦
然後後來我說剛才我講完一堂課
我找徒刑
把我所說的東西
為什麼為什麼為什麼告訴你
所以兩堂課其實是一堂課
一堂課是講一些食物的東西
另外一堂課是把K線帶給你了解
那五堂課就變成十堂課
那麼中間有人會有問題
有人會有問題
那麼我會在現場
那麼請林教授為你們解答問題
因為林教授學的時間比較長
比較久 它未來也會是老師
所以舞堂課變成十三堂課
老師加碼十三堂課就是超棒的
超級難得的一次的課程
然後另外呢
就是其實很多同學都會在邊想說
那老師 舞堂課都是那個
就是自由的一個現土了
那其實真正考驗功力的是什麼
是白天 對
所以呢 其實我們在這一次的課程裡面
還有群組的一個老師
老師其實歷屆都是這樣子
老師都會用群組上面
然後白天做給你看
因為代表就是
晚上我教的是沒有錯的
因為我就是用這樣
我記得老師也是講說他
你很喜歡就是同學來吐槽你
看能不能被吐槽到這樣
對 因為我們這樣講
技術分析一定要手把手
教的 事後教都沒有用
很多很多很多的同學
或者學生或者投資人
他們都有個感慨
一說這樣 這國買票
這國買票反而事後再說都很簡單
但是當下你做給我看
印證給我看
我覺得這才是重點
這才是學習技術分析
因為你要去學習
小朋友都在思考什麼
在這個點頭為什麼要做這個動作
做這動作之後是對還是錯
沒有如果 只有結果
是
那麼我就在盤中
不管日盤 或夜盤
不管股票或者是起伙
我做給你看
在做給你看之前
我可能會先說給你聽
你注意什麼心想做什麼心想
讓我做出來給你看
你再去印證
不可是不是符合這種情況
是不是符合這種情況
你將血東西才會快
才能夠真的
完全融入到技術分析體裡面
以後你才能夠在江湖上混
是
有 因為老師都說了
操作就是為了要賺錢
這句話我覺得印象超級深刻的
你操作如果在研究對跟錯 浪費時間
好 我們非常期待從11月23號開始的
我們這13堂的一個課程是
一級技術分析工藝巴黎